[Music]
you know life can be rough sometimes and
you never know when someone could use a
little inspirational message
so i'd like to offer some up right now
to no one in particular
in a segment called i don't know who
needs to hear this
but i do
i don't know who needs to hear this but
you don't need him
you never did you're gonna get through
this breakup and emerged better than you
were before
belinda gates i don't know who needs to
hear this but
you don't need to lose all that weight
you are beautiful just the way you
are adele i don't know who needs to hear
this but
you miss 100 of the shots you don't take
anti-vaxxers now i don't know who needs
to hear this but
just because you're a successful
businessman doesn't mean you should be
mayor of new york
andrew yang i don't know who needs to
hear this but
and that coat is techie cruella de vil
i don't know who needs to hear this but
you don't have to imitate the way other
people talk to get attention you can
just be yourself
kate winslet i don't know who needs to
hear this but
shh no tone it down upstairs neighbors
and finally i don't know who needs to
hear this but
life isn't always a straight path
sometimes
life can take you on a journey that's
full of twists and turns and
sometimes that journey leads you to new
places
but sometimes it takes you right back to
exactly where you started
and if it does that's okay jlo
and ben affleck this has been i don't
know who needs to hear this
but i do
[Music]
you